i'll tell you where we first met where
did we first meet at a gq party fox i'll
actually tell that story all right you
said to me you smell like weed and i
said
i am weed
and then
you vanished
hi i'm megan fox hi i'm colson baker is
that your real name
sometimes
and this is
the gq couple quiz
okay
how many tattoos do i have
name them out while you it's best to go
by your ankle back of your neck
to nietzsche
you have it
back
you got ours
you got my nickname
and then the one i just gave you and
then the one right below the one i gave
you which is the yin yang
[Music]
that one doesn't count no that one
doesn't count my other rib cage is also
tattooed that's what i said you only
said nietzsche in my back oh well count
the other rib cage too that's nine right
the bonus if you want to redeem yourself
is
what does my back tattoo say the one on
my question
close you're in the vicin that's not
correct but do you know what it's from
oscar wilde no
shakespeare ah
go for the butterflies go for it i know
you can do it butterflies
no
there's a butterfly in there but that's
not how it starts
we
we will all laugh at the butterflies
with gilded wings so close we all laugh
at gilded butterflies it's from king
here and by shakespeare okay what does
the nietzsche quote on my ribs say we
are doing ap literature class right now
that is for sure not okay you get
because you were close on the number
i'll give you one half of a point for
that but that was rough what's something
on my bucket list
be abducted by a ufo
i'll give you two points for that
two points
um what was my first acting role
oh mary kate and ashley oh
and oh the soap opera that you won't let
me watch if i swear to god if you play
clips from that play clips
cracked i'll give you a point for that
okay what is my biggest pet peeve
when i eat
and i'm talking to you in your ear i
don't think it has to be related to you
specifically like just what's my picture
yeah but that but that that's kind of
the sound of chewing yeah yeah there's a
name for that i have that what was my
favorite movie as a kid it's really hard
to decipher when like we still watch
kid movies all the time
hook you stand by
okay i'll give you a point for that
what's my favorite movie now and if you
don't know this
i'm going to be very upset at you what's
my favorite movie now i can't wait for
it to get cold and i'm going to make it
no no no no no you don't you don't have
to you don't have to go there it's like
an eight series piece we're talking
about harry mother
potter yes don't think that
one is my favorite obviously prisoners
of azkaban prisoner prisoner of azkaban
yes yes that was the best book too okay
agreed i'll give you three points for
that okay what film am i most proud of
easy jennifer's body yeah eating
boys left and right
where is my favorite place to visit i
mean any place that was
around for thousands of years any place
that has histories your answer is
nebulous but i will
count it as mostly correct the
straight-up answer would be the forest a
tree okay fine the forest period yeah or
any anywhere without people or buildings
or electricity yeah
where did we first meet and what or when
was our first date
well what was our first date our first
day was epic our first day i picked up
that was our first like out of the house
date but
and i had roses thousands of rows
thousands of roses
bedded on a on a hill
looking over to panga canyon
and we ate
sushi we shared a kiss
and our our first date
our first date we breathed each other
that was what we did
and then our second day
what did i want to be when i was a kid
oh you want to be an actor since you
were two
correct i'm not keeping track of your
points but you're doing good
what is my
hidden talent
no
buddha don't you dare don't
you dare okay
only pg rated answers okay god well one
your i your iq is if you were my
jeopardy partner you could would
honestly win every single category i've
never you you are an almanac and
encyclopedia and dictionary all-in-one
okay so my hidden talent is that i'm not
stupid i appreciate you that's five
points i love you i mean if he doesn't
there's no way he doesn't know this what
is my astrological sign
yeah i mean
i don't even know the answer to this
question how old was i when i started
modeling let's both guess one count
three one two three twelve
[Music]
okay let's find out
what's my favorite way to decompress
after a long day
do you want to tell them what the doctor
said
we cannot say how do you even know what
it is
okay look what the doctor said was you
are insane we cannot say that on campus
that's your favorite way for me to
decompress after a stressful day what's
my favorite way to decompress after a
stressful day that would be
tea
and a foot massage and reading a book
and watching a show together
probably crying a few tears definitely
crying for sure
like she loves a good cry
yeah he gets that's all of those things
were correct that's like an eight point
eight point question
who is my best friend
me
beyond you whoa mindy
ouch well you're not allowed to say you
oh are you not no clearly you're your
best friend obviously you're the best
okay because i'm just going all the way
knights of you just looking at me
repeatedly saying you're my best friend
it's it it's obviously hard to
but you know
what was my character's name in teenage
mutant ninja turtles if you don't know
that i can't i can't help you in life if
you don't know that
who was i in teenage mutant ninja
turtles
she wears a yellow i got it yeah it's my
favorite picture of you it's the one
where you have the ankle weights on and
can we not because yeah no i want them
to and she's outside working out and
she's she's like
and she's just working out and i like
she has like low top dunks on or
something it's the cutest picture i've
ever seen in my life and i i send her it
often and she hates me for it buddha you
get zero april o'neil april oh
okay you definitely know this one i had
a role on the show new girl what was my
character's name reagan
you killed that role by the way great
job i love you on that show
buddha that was very good you did very
well this is how many you got right
it's a lot your turn okay my love
what's my actual name
colson baker what are my nicknames mgk
machine gun what are you what are your
nicknames for me oh is that what that
means
buddha
lambie you haven't gotten that one in a
long while but you gotta earn that one
back cookie
blonde angel baby
am i missing any you have endless
there's so many those are the main ones
those are the most used
okay they were great that was good you
don't have a middle name
can i guess what your middle name will
be yeah guess what my middle name will
be when i leave played that's what i
want sword katana no blade blade chaos
blade is what hectic violence
yeah i like black
no but do you remember what house he was
in
yeah gryffindor was he what's my shoe
size okay so you used to think it was a
13 and then you thought it was a 12 but
we've settled on an 11 but i actually
think that's impossible because you are
20 feet tall show people your feet it's
the most ridiculous thing i've ever seen
his shoes weigh 15 pounds we don't know
my shoe size
yeah how many tattoos do i have
it's literally impossible to calculate
well you know what it was impossible to
calculate a shakespeare quote
you've tattooed on top of your tattoos
on top of your tattoos so how many
tattoos have i gotten since i've known
you
what's my favorite tattoo the one i did
on you i tattooed you the one on your
hip with my initials and then the other
one
probably that one right yeah that one
hurts my heart
how do i like my coffee mostly black and
bitter but i've convinced you to take it
with oat milk and a little bit of sugar
to sweeten you up in the morning you say
that every time you offer me sugar you
go don't you just want a little bit of
sugar to sweeten you up yeah it's like
aerobatic you need a little bit of a
sweet flavor in your body instead of
putting the bitter in you're already
there we don't need anything
what's my favorite comic series or comic
book
what's my favorite comic book character
of all time you know this lucifer 100
yeah
followed by saying that what's my
favorite comic series
ice cream man
whatever it's called i love that one
what was my first ever job
i don't know how we want to
characterize your first job weren't you
like selling that makes it sound like i
was a prostitute no but you were like
selling your own cds and stuff when you
were like 13. what was my first like
job that i had to have a w for no
there's something before that
i worked at a grocery store oh you did
tell me that but i didn't know in the
timeline if that fell before or after
the airbrush that was fourteen i worked
at dave's supermarket
oh god what's our favorite show to watch
together no you're gonna don't
don't what do you think preface it oh
it's what i know it's what do you think
oh it's what i mean it is what you think
okay i'll just name a few of them okay
big little lies
the second show
is nine perfect strangers
uber cap you can't wait to see how that
unfolds
and then you also loved the thread line
is nicole kidman because you also love
the undoing and that show was fire and i
dare you to tell me that it wasn't you
could not wait to watch that show you
could not wait you could not wait but he
always comes home acting like he doesn't
want to see it like i make him watch it
but if i'm like okay let's not watch it
let's do something else then he like
finds ways to circle back and make sure
that i end up putting it on because he
can't stand to not give me their hat
someone give me their hat so i could
show this cat i can't believe that you
don't recognize i'm only
being a supportive tv and knowing that
you like watching the shows and i'm like
let's watch what you like so what is the
right answer like you watch south park
and stuff like that but that's not
that's not what you want to watch when
you come home after work with me let's
be real be honest and then we like to
talk about what the characters are doing
i'm super done now what do i never leave
the house without something to smoke
usually a lighter although you lose
those and steal everyone else's
way too much cash totally unnecessary
backpack you have to take that with you
everywhere you go or hide it even when
it's in our own home when no one could
ever get in
now you're nailing it this is all this
is this is hilarious because i just know
where you're gonna go with this what
does my perfect day off look like
i mean there is no day off is the point
she thinks that i work all the time
when's the last time you had a day off
when we went to bora bora in january
almost a year ago
if i did have a day off what would it
look like what did we do in bora bora
that day
how long did we walk on that gravel road
an eternity because we ate mushrooms
those mushrooms were very strong
so your day off would be us wandering
around on mushrooms yes and when and
then what did we see at night as soon as
the system of a downside was slow
for real i know i was there
how many albums do i have
five working on the sixth about to be
released what's the name of the sixth
album
born with horns
is it good
it's very good
if i was an animal what animal would i
be told
no no no no no
you can literally google any machine gun
kelly photo and then if you also google
any meerkat photo
and you split screen those oh i hate you
you cannot tell the difference do that
right now because it's ever looked more
does my personality remind you of
sometimes like a bunny rabbit because
you're sensitive and like also
frightened and like fragile
and then other times like
dragon you say dragon but it's
mythological but i feel like that's not
who comes out in the streets that's not
a dragon because dragons are very like
regal and would be in control of their
like they're wise what's that person
that comes out something like the hulk
yeah yeah
what's my sun
sign
your sun is taurus your moon is pisces
your rising is gemini
you have a stellium of planets and
pisces your son is in the 12th house
which is the house that's ruled by
neptune which is the ruler of pisces
you're very piscean and you're very
gemini
very morose and the moods
are very intense but i know the whole
chart
okay well obviously you win this game
but we're gonna finish this out just for
the people what's my favorite place to
visit
travis's studio
you've never been on a vacation your
first vacation was with me
what's my favorite show i've ever played
i don't know i bet red rocks is one of
them for sure one of your favorite
venues for sure i don't know like
specific shows there's been thousands
yeah i mean obviously cleveland hometown
stuff is a go-to for me but yeah i mean
the red rocks like the last time i did
red rocks it was
juice world opening
and us closing and i felt
when i went on stage i could
feel my aunt's energy come down
and she was with me on that she always
dreamed that she could see me
play there but she passed before she
could so that was cool like
feeling her there that night
and that's the last question did i pick
any up i feel like i got them all all
right i wouldn't give her something
yeah you got 99. is it a tie yeah i feel
like i got 99 as well how many points
did i get baby you get
these many points
i gave you so many bonus points i gave
you a lot of bonus points as well did
you yeah i did i appreciate you yeah you
were killing it
well that was it everyone clearly he's
completely exhausted from the experience
thank you for watching i hope you had
fun
me too
do you want to tell the people what the
doctor said
look
the doctor said
every day
megan has to do